now is the shadow Health and Social care
Minister Andrew Gwynn Andrew morning to
you thanks for joining us on Skinny's
breakfast
let's start with those NHS strikes then
and Stephen Barkley being accused of
bullying nurses is he a bully
well look as Pat Collins has said she
wants to be in the negotiating room not
the courtroom and it's incumbent on the
government to do all they can to to
avoid the situation that we're heading
into
it's incumbent on them to pull every
stop out who negotiate with the Royal
College of Nursing and to get a
settlement that can find a way through
there has to be compromise we know that
but uh you know really
um Steve Barkley and Richie sunac have
failed to sit down with the nurses until
the 11th hour so the failure it really
lands at the door of the Prime Minister
and the health secretary here a Mr Gwen
would labor be able to offer a pay rise
above five percent
well look it's not just about pay
speaking to nurses they are incredibly
angry at the way the government has
treated them we're talking about a group
of people here who were black during the
pandemic they are the heroes of the
moment uh and yet all the uh problems
that have stored up over the NHS not
just because of the pandemic but because
of years of Tory failure uh on the
workforce and so on it is about terms
and conditions it is about nurses
feeling overwhelmed with work uh because
of those staff shortages and the
government has failed to address those
things uh there isn't a proper Workforce
strategy in place and what we've said is
that the labor party will prioritize
these issues in government we will make
sure that the next generation of doctors
nurses
um medical workers and staff support are
there to support the current cohort
nurses in the NHS that's the important
thing having a Workforce strategy and a
government that is determined to work
with the existing staff to resolve the
issues in the NHS it's not just about
pay it's about terms conditions and the
workforce
ultimately you know there are nurses
that are having to work perhaps second
jobs who are having to use food banks
what would labor do specifically for pay
well of course Labor's not in government
these are questions you need to level at
Steve Barkley and Rishi sunach the the
fact is we are heading into another
period of industrial action the
government has to properly focus on the
issues that matter to the nurses and
ensure that those issues are resolved
I've said
well I've said what a future labor
government would do we would have worked
uh day and night to avert these strikes
by sitting down at the earliest possible
opportunity with the nursing unions who
work out a package that would be
acceptable not just on pay but on terms
and conditions and more importantly to
solve the long-term issues of the
workforce shortages in our NHS because
that goes to the very roots of the
issues that are facing the nurses and
their professional bodies right now and
what's your position on the strikes do
you support them
I don't want to see uh strikes in the
NHS but I understand the anger of those
professionals that are taking the
decision to go out on strike uh I think
that you know these uh Professionals in
particular were talking about the nurses
feel completely deflated they feel
completely
um unloved and so it's incumbent on the
government to sit down and find a
practical solution a way through this so
that we can rebuild our NHS and tackle
the very real issues that need tackling
not least cutting those waiting times
cutting those waiting lists and getting
patients the care that they deserve and
the care that they need and Mr Gwen I'd
like to get your thoughts on Dominic
Robb's resignation if I may
um particularly his resignation letter
uh was that apology enough
no and quite frankly it was shocking
that he doubled down uh on the report
that was released into his behavior look
um there can be no place for bullying
and uh there have been rumors permeating
that the corridors of Westminster for
many many months about Dominic Robb's
alleged behavior in not just his current
department but previous departments
um people have blown the whistle on
Dominic Robb's behavior in those
departments there has been an
independent investigation into Mr Rob
and he has been found to be a bully in
some of those instances uh I don't think
he should have been given the privilege
of resigning in his own terms actually
Rishi sunap should have shown that
leadership uh he said when he came into
Downing Street he would lead a
government of integrity and he's failed
on his own terms he should have sacked
Dominic Rob in fact I'd go further he
knew the allegations he knew what we was
being said about Mr Rob I think he
probably shouldn't have appointed him as
Deputy Prime Minister in the first place
how do you think political parties that
can make sure that bullying doesn't
happen in the future because there's a
lot to be said about what's happening at
the moment but not many people are
talking I suppose about those civil
servants who some might say were very
brave to come forward and voice their
concerns
absolutely and I think we pride
ourselves in the United Kingdom that we
have an independent Civil Service a
permanent civil service that will
um serve the government of the day
irrespective of the party in power and
there will be some incredible civil
servants that have served uh the labor
governments of Tony Blair and Gordon
Brown gone on to serve the Coalition
governments of uh of David Cameron and
Nick Clegg and then gone on to serve the
conservative governments of David
Cameron of Theresa May of Boris Johnson
of list trust very briefly and now of
Rishi sunak and have done so
professionally quite in contrast but say
the uh United States of America where
they are political appointments and when
that pendulum swings in politics the
civil service is cleared out and a new
set of civil servants are brought in to
serve their political Masters I think
it's an incredible system here in the
United Kingdom but ministers have to
treat the civil servants with respect
it's right that they demand correct
information from civil servants it's
right but they demand uh the detail that
they need to go about making the
decisions in government but to bully
members of Staff in any way place not
just a civil service it's unacceptable
and ministers have an absolute duty to
treat their civil servants in their
departments with utmost respect and with
professionalism
okay uh Andrew Quinn Shadow Health and
Social care Minister thanks for your
time this morning thank you